this prime not those old years where he
just can't get it up you get will get
there just give me a minute
oh you think you could baked off by them
more easily than you could pay off more
I'm fast
although Darth Maul was pretty good he
had a double-ended dildo thing yeah yeah
yeah I can I cut off my father's hand
we're talking with like a hacksaw right
not like a lightsaber oh that's how I do
it I mean if you have got more than one
son obviously yah his toes do you have
to suck them we can just lick them
alcohol I do the tail I'm not I'm not
good at toes whoa are you gonna be
looking iContact to layer as you look
don't you look at me do you want to say
it at the same time three two one r2d2
come on because if they're literally
like little naked Chewbacca's why would
they be naked why are they naked in your
head I'm gonna make it I don't I don't I
want the full body pew Bork
I want them shaved it's what you're
saying no no I want pubic hair I want to
go 70s
full bush
[Music]